let's say national monogamy isn't quite
your thing and maybe you have an
entirely legitimate reason you have
family abroad or you live and work in
another country but maybe you wish to be
by national for more nefarious reasons
perhaps you like to play shell games
with your money to avoid paying local
taxes or it could be that you lead a
double life or maybe you just need a
place to lay low free what you need is a
second Passport and fortunately you can
get one for cash here's how now under
most circumstances becoming a citizen of
two nations isn't as easy as say getting
Hulu and Netflix most countries have
strict residency requirements that last
years but some will let you buy your way
in now in some cases the cost can be
absorbed Austria for example has a
killer passport with visa-free access to
168 countries including the United
States but it's likely to cost you north
of 10 million dollars after you've
invested that some in local Austrian
businesses Malta has a better deal it
too has a nice EU passport which gets
him into 163 countries visa-free but
should only cost you a little bit more
than a million bucks and local
investments Malta's Eastern neighbours
Cyprus also has an EU friendly
citizenship program but it costs
millions of dollars more and given
recent Cypriot economic upheaval may be
more trouble than it's worth but for a
real bargain head to the Caribbean for
decades the island nation of st. Kitts
and Nevis has had a program that grants
citizenship for as little as a $250,000
investment
the nation of Antigua and Barbuda
matched that fee and of the two
st. Kitts may have a sweeter set it
edges out Antigua in the number of
countries you can visit visa-free and
has no direct personal taxation
whatsoever
Nevis even has a Four Seasons Resort so
you can get all that visa-free travel
and non-existent taxation alongside some
frozen grapes brought to you cool